[Music]
my name is Karen Lynn I'm the general
manager here at sukkah my second why is
a modern Japanese izakaya located on a
Lower East Side of Manhattan so the walk
yukata Sandow is a beef cutlet sandwich
katsu is cutlet in Japanese Sandow is
short for sandwich and Wagyu is a high
quality beef from Japanese cattle it is
really expensive because of the amount
of time and effort it goes into raising
the cattle and the result is beautiful
tender delicious flavorful meat the
marbling is definitely a lot more than
your ordinary beef there's a lot more
depth and flavor in the fat itself katsu
Sando is a comfort food in Japan you
know you can get at Japanese deli but
you can also get it at a high-end
restaurant so it could be very gourmet
or just everyday like street food
so we get a nice cut of strip point we
use a five Miyazaki Wagyu from Miyazaki
Prefecture it grades on yield and
quality so a is the highest yield grade
and five is the quality of the marbling
so Ava is the highest rating for Wagyu
after we cut it it's very simple we just
season it with salt and pepper we do the
batter with the egg and then we put the
breading on it the breading is panco
which is a japanese-style
breadcrumbs and then after that you know
it's ready to go in the fryer and that
part is actually the probably the most
difficult part making sure that it's
coming out at the right temperature in
the fryer that's where the skill comes
into and making a good cuts angle after
the cut so is fried we put the sauce on
it
tonkatsu sauce is very important any
kind of cuts in the dish there's grated
onion in it some ketchup mustard
mayonnaise a little Wurster sauce and I
think a lot of times if the sauce isn't
good it just doesn't compliment the meat
and we figured out a good blend of
tonkatsu sauce the bread that we use is
Japanese milk bread which is in Japan
called sugar palm it's a little bit
fluffier and sweeter and we definitely
want to toast it gives a little bit more
crunch to the bread then we spread a
mummy butter on it there's a little bit
of chicken fat in it so it kind of gives
that mummy punch then we assemble the
sandwich and cut off the crust and
present them on the plate while you just
started coming in I think five six years
ago and I think because of social media
and the internet you know like everyone
knows about it now and you know looking
into this beef katsu Sando and trying it
on our own it's good it's really
delicious this is a take on Japanese
comfort food that people haven't really
explored as much and we're excited that
we're one of the first in New York to
explore that and really share it with
in New York
[Music]